Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
We are back, and today we are going to be finishing Resident
Evil Requiem!
Yes, it's going to be a long stream, so grab your popcorns,
grab the bottle, grab a blanket, we're here for the long
haul.
Anyway, guys, um, have some good news.
Um, the Doki merch anniversary stuff, pre-ordered, order has
been extended to another week so i saw some dragons asking
for an extension um and i see you guys i hear you so uh the
doki merch uh will be uh pre-orders will be extended for
another week uh so pre-orders will officially end on the
14th so if you guys uh for those who have yet to you know
have a chance to pre-order it you still have one more week
uh to pre-order the doki can get uh will be like here you go
let me grab the plushie because i forgot to tweet about it
either i also wanted extension so i could tweet about the
newest plushie design so it would look like this yeah i'm
also how getting the sample uh the sample on monday too so
i'm so excited so i can actually bring the mini doki around
with me so stuff including like this plushie uh the
extension uh you can have one more week to pre-order it uh
other than that uh I also want to talk about the Watson
plushie, too.
You have three days left to pre-order the Doki Watson
plushie for Apex Legends.
And also, okay, so I was, for those who were wondering, I
was this close to adding another mod to my Resident Evil
gameplay.
Because apparently they finally came, not the Shrek one.
I did see it, but we're already past that stage, so there's
no point in adding the Shrek.
mod because like we all know in the resident evil community
there's two well-known mods that everyone uses and it's the
shrek mod and the and the thomas the tank engine mod but
anyway so they finally added shirtless leon with like with
like sweating where you can actually see like the sweats on
his body so they actually added a sweating shirtless leon uh
mod into the game and I was this close to add the mod I
didn't do it though I was a coward guys I guys I'm sorry I
I'm a coward I didn't do it I you coward a fake fan go add
it well wait next you think it was super chat thing no you
guys don't understand my the last rest of evil play through
our the last Resident Evil stream, we got restricted guys.
We got R18 restricted.
We can't let this happen again.
I don't know what for though.
It could be it could be for either the gore or because I
swore too much.
Not because of Thomas the tank engine though.
Not because I don't know.
It could be because I swore too much or it was because there
was too much gore.
I can't tell, but I can't let it happen.
I don't want to test my odds.
You know, I don't want to test their system.
I'll test the YouTube bots.
So unfortunately, there is, I have to be up front with you
guys.
But there is no shirtless Leon mod in this.
I did not add the shirtless Leon mod.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know, Doki, I'm canceling my pre-order the anniversary
merch.
Can't support a cow.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Brokenbot, thank you for chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Amon, thank you for the Aka Supa, thank you.
Go down, Amon, thank you for the Aka Supa, thank you.
Guys, I'll get too, we'll all get too distracted, guys.
We can't, guys, how will we pay attention to the story and
the plot, which is very important to Resident Evil if we all
get too distracted with what's in front of us like how will
we pay attention next see thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you so what you're saying is if we give you enough
money to make up for the restriction then it's okay to add
the money thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
simple thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
shortlist leon or i unsubscribe i will do it don't test me
dokey simple thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you solid stink thank you the super chat thank you thank you
if we're getting restricted let's give them a good reason
then we can no way also we did not get restricted for thomas
the tank engine oh my gosh i saw someone made a comment and
i was like that was so clever i wish i stole that in time
they were like the t and t virus stands for thomas and i'm
like oh my that was so clever i wish i stole that in time
for my commentary uh thank you thank you for the one gift
that I'll do a compromise.
How about this?
We'll have shirtless Leon for the police station.
Okay, how about that?
Until we swap the grace.
We'll have shirtless Leon until we swap the grace.
How is that for a compromise, guys?
No, we don't negotiate.
Yippee, oh, yippee, all right, I see that.
Talk to you the super chat thing.
If no Leon, at least give...
All right, all right, let me grab shirtless Leon real quick.
guys all right only for for the police station and then and
then when and then um the rest will be closed leon and then
we'll have club leon after all right let's see where is it i
need to find shortlist leon guys give me a sec
actually there is their way to do grace there i saw a mod
where you can have it where it's it's just all leon like the
entire game is just all leon like even grace by the way
there's like play the entire game as just leon i wish i wish
i did that for this playthrough i'm
Gus, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you, oh, okay, I'm reordering, you might as well buy
two, two of each of the merch after this, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you, pay attention to the
story, there are tons of videos for that, we're here to see
dokey dokey shenanigans, download the mod, thank you, thank
you, thank you, Mr. Broken Bomb, thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, Oh, yeah, basically,
this is what it looks like.
For those who are wondering what it looks like for if we
just play all Leon, here's a picture of it.
It's literally Leon on Leon action.
I wish this mod came out when I started playing this game.
Because I would have 100% downloaded that.
All right, let me find it, guys.
not a good username thank you for super chat thank you thank
you please keep leon shirt on i have a strict no shirt no
shoes no stream policy they give a super chat not a good
username thank you thank you they even have shaved leon but
but what's the point it doesn't make him look rugged okay
let's see i'm trying to find it there's several very okay
all right so all right i'll let you guys vote for the leon
you want do you want fully shirtless leon or like leon
shirtless but he has like his tactical gear on like money
has gone too far yes all right here i'll give a pull
shirtless leon or shirtless leon but tactical gear
shirtless leon shirtless leon with tactical gear all right
i'll let the fans vote okay what's the difference between
wait let me check how do i get one or the other
okay he has this how do i get his jacket off like is this
jack oh it's jack is already off yeah it's that gear the
gear stays all right guys what i'm just worried i'm like i
feel like i'm definitely gonna get rat restricted again all
right okay i'll give you guys the comparison i'll give you i
i know i'm gonna get i know i'm gonna get like i'm gonna get
rat restricted here the comparison all right and then let me
all right here here are the two comparisons uh it's this
version i'll make it tiniest so it'll confuse the youtube
bots uh the ai bots this version or there's the other
version Oh god, that's too big.
I gotta, I gotta shrink it a little.
It's too shiny.
It's like, I'm freaking out, but it's, he's surprising.
The Leon Gray should be young.
Leon from Resident Evil 2 remake.
Thank you.
Oh, don't give them ideas, guys.
They might steal it.
Uh, Shady, thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
There is a no pants version asking for a friend.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
Leon Thuris says, overrated as fuck.
I am a simple grace and joyer.
Rector, thank you for chatting.
Thank you.
Alright, gear stays on.
Alright, let me download this.
Yes, download.
I didn't remember how to...
I didn't remember how to do this.
It's been a while.
Alright.
I mean, it's been a while, as in it's been a few days and I
already forgot.
Alright, uh, browse local files where did i keep these mods
where did i keep it oh there you go was it this yeah because
there's thomas
the higher with close theory all right all right we'll go
with the tactical gear leon only for the police station okay
it's because the lore of it because so that it makes sense
you know he's back at his old place back where he began and
he's like he got to relax he's like god it's so hot here
because the the missiles or the nuclear bomb changed the
weather in raccoon city so it's extra hot so that's why he
had to take off his shirt but because of his giant inventory
he needs his inventory and his items um he has to keep his
tactical gear on to store all the ammo you know like it has
to make sense but when he's out of raccoon city um he puts
his clothes back on it's just that it's just so hot in
raccoon city that he just has to take off his shirt you know
guys just so he doesn't die from from heat exhaustion uh
from overheating uh fudge top thank you for super chat thank
you thank you have you seen the game over restart meme of
leon just saying uh since i know my i have no idea what that
is thank you the super chat thank you thank you rice thank
you with super chat thank you thank you his giant inventory
yeah sure thank you for the super chat thank thank you all
right let's see is it done it's not even done loading yet
guys all right let me try remember how to mod this uh he
just doesn't want to get a heat actually supposed to be
snowing in raccoon city but they didn't want to repeat a
snow theme that's why that's why it's so hot they went the
opposite direction guys and he doesn't he doesn't want they
don't want leon to die from heatstroke you know heatstroke
is very um you know heatstroke is very serious matter see
look at the united kingdom a lot of people are dying from
heatstrokes because a lot of the buildings in the uk is not
does not have the right ventilation and also air
conditioning built to sustain for the weather that it's that
summer vacate that summer gives now because of global
warning so this is like a PSA for everybody to make sure you
take off your shirt when it gets too hot so you don't want
to die from a heat stroke thank you Leon we should say thank
you Leon for this PSA and for doing God's work on educating
us on the dangers of heat strokes exactly safety first
Thank you for your service, Leon.
I know it's so hard to fight shirtless.
Why don't you...
I have an air conditioning.
There's no air conditioning.
Raccoon City.
Officer, it was too sunny.
I swear.
All right.
Let's see.
I have it downloaded.
All right.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where is that mod?
call it shirtless leon okay all right let's add it in all
right where is it shirtless leon mod let's go i need to put
in the mods folder all right let's unpack this extract all
just like asking right it has some straps on as or nothing
of course the gear stays on patria said thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you all right this should work
all right let's see if it does work uh all right i'm gonna
adjust the sound real quick guys uh wait what's the audio
for it was like all right there you go all right booting up
the game now and see if it works I need to make sure loose
file loader and pack directory loader is enabled.
Oh shit, wait.
I almost forgot.
Wait, I didn't do it right.
Give me a sec.
We have to...
I almost forgot to do something important for this.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
It's not done yet.
These guys said you all can wait.
Alright, mod manager.
There we go.
Mod manager.
And then I have to move.
There's this.
There we go.
It's in.
It's in now.
Alright.
Now I'll boot up Resident Evil.
We're doing it in real time.
Not your Resident Evil.
a super chat thank you thank you assuming you use the proper
tool you need to move the zip to the same folder as thomas
then run fluffy and should handle the rest patra said they
use super chat thank you thank you don't worry i got it the
mod is in it's in now
okay i gotta make sure about something real quick too
uh requiem real quick.
I knew it.
Alright.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Oh.
Where is it?
Where did it go?
Leon is too much.
No!
Crash!
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
Is shirtless Leon too much?
Wait, wait, don't worry.
We got this.
All right, we gotta make sure this is enabled.
Oh, was it this?
I think this has to be enabled, too.
We gotta make sure, yeah, this is enabled now.
All right, here we go.
Round two.
Round two, guys.
All right.
Oh, no.
shirtless leon too much is it actually too much guys oh no
let me double check let me double check everybody we might
we might have a problem no i'm saying it ain't so not my
shirtless leon give me a sec i have an idea all right we'll
get rid of this and then all right here we go the game can't
handle shirtless leon damn it don't get go png so i can see
my leon all right let's see if this works
all right
Checking add-ons, please.
All right.
Everything seems okay so far, guys.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait.
I think I have an idea.
Wait, wait, guys.
I'll do one more.
One more.
I think there's a reason why it didn't work.
This is...
so sad my leon is it oh is it the newest reframe work i
don't know this one was downloaded during for the the thomas
stream is this the newest one analyze i have all this stuff
oh wait there we go it didn't take again i don't know why it
doesn't take it has all the newest one latest is two days
Oh, this is the file.
Okay, wait.
Is my game broken?
Because it's the reframe work.
They have a new reframe work.
All right, let's see.
I didn't get to take it before.
You didn't restart the game after.
Oh, oh, after enabling it.
Oh, okay.
I restarted after I enabled it.
We were so excited.
We will make this work.
First.
Leon, do it for Leon.
I will try with that.
Okay, after enabling that option.
Okay, and then we close the game.
Alright, game has been closed.
I only have one thing modded and one thing only.
And only one thing added.
Okay.
Let's see if it works now.
Let's see if it's saved.
No, it didn't save.
Oh, maybe if I exit it correctly.
Does it auto save or not to take it every time?
Okay, maybe if I do that and then quit it naturally, it'll
save.
All right.
I can download the new reframe work too to see if that
works.
When did they last updated this on March 4th?
When was my last Resident Evil playthrough?
The things we do.
Oh, it makes it more worth it, guys.
When it works, it makes...
The weight makes it worth it even more.
Like...
When we get it to work...
Just think, guys.
Just think.
It makes it...
Oh, wait.
It didn't save again.
I'll close this.
And then we'll...
He's just playing hard to get, guys.
He's just playing hard to get.
Why is Leon teasing us?
He knows how bad we want it.
They're trying to cast a Christmas slow bird.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You will let Leon keep his shape.
see if not we'll just download the new free framework it
could just be that this is version 1.5.91 plus 411 i have no
idea if that is the correct version all right nope all right
we gotta download the new reframwork then oh leon and if
anything i will also all right uh but but but for up to date
check out github resident evil 9 where where is it where the
fuck is resident evil 9 1 at the download uh can we download
from the releases page wait 1.5.91
wait let me check out let me read the thing just to be sure
guys play as oh wait that's the play as leon in every game
mode uh by pray dot enable both then restart the game for
the mod to load uh to ensure it's there and put the hole in
the mod's folder and stole it through don't extract the file
there don't worry i did not i definitely did not do that i
definitely did not accidentally extract the entire thing
it's all okay wait where did the file go though accident
remove wait where did it go wait where did the file go oh
wait that's okay let me did i accidentally up my no no okay
i didn't i see the mods folder where the top wait i was
gonna say where did the thomas mod go the thomas mod oh it's
because i took it out right if I turn it on will it reappear
in my folder oh it does that's so weird if I turn it off it
reappears in my folder don't worry I have it back on how did
I know it do does that that's funny okay and then uh gonna
delete this all right uh no don't worry i have the leon mod
back let's see yeah
uh and then i gotta make sure the reframe work is the new
reframe work we're modding live chat we're Doing it live.
Nika, thank you for the rate.
Thank you.
Hope you had a good stream.
Where the fuck is Resident Evil 9?
You're not using race tracing.
Otherwise, just down.
For example, you're using...
Where the fuck is it?
Resident Evil 2, 3, 4, 7?
Where the fuck is 9?
How do I download for 9?
Okay, wait, guys.
I'm trying to find...
There is a 2...
three four seven eight i don't even see nine
i've tried there's street fighter there's double may cry
five there's monster i'm on the wrong page am i on okay
reframe work the wrong page i remember it poorly Oh, is it
the nightly developer builds?
Oh, my God.
I still don't see nine.
I see nine.
I found him.
I found him, guys.
I found it.
All right.
I don't remember how I did this, though, guys.
I think it's like, I put it in here.
And then I...
delete the reframe work one where did I put it okay delete
open oh my god how do I do this again we're learning how to
do this live right now because I don't remember how I did I
delete the old reframe work and then I extract the new one
in with the new out with the old I extract it all.
And then I put it all in here.
And I replace this file.
And now we boot the game.
There you go.
The things we do for Leon.
Alright.
then most likely i didn't break the game i hope okay all
right here you go this is i don't know if this is new or old
this has to be the new one all right maybe we could see leon
for a little bit it might crash but at least we get to see
him for a little bit you know like we try to get in before
it and put it up before it crashes.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
I told you it was worth it.
I told you.
Yes.
For Leon, I told you guys.
Oh my god, way too many guns on me.
This is all tactical.
shit.
This is everything.
I told ladies and gentlemen, we got him.
We got him, ladies and gentlemen.
I told you guys, he was just playing hard again.
His lack of shirt stabilized the entire game.
Turn the camera again.
Don't worry, I'll do it Slowly, dude.
Oh, Leon, why don't you want to show your pretty face for
us?
Stop.
Come on, Leon.
Don't be hard again.
We got you.
Bro, he has this new tattooed on.
No, it's just extra tight.
So it has to be extra strapped on.
You know?
He doesn't want things to fall off.
Guys, obviously.
Just trying to make sure nothing falls apart.
You know, guys?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't you have mods?
The camera is always on the front.
Guys, calm down.
Calm down.
We only get this for the police station.
So we gotta savor it.
Alright.
we gotta savor every moment common think of the super chat
thank you thank you common sense bro that's true this mod
adds two more guns on the inventory think of the super chat
thank you thank you all right oh he's talking oh my god is
that westker also i just found out westker is not british he
just happens to have a british accent in some of the games
he's in and also the action i he has always been american i
didn't know that he just has he just sounds british in some
games he sounds like a british bond villain patria said
thank you for the uh akasupa thank you thank you i'm sure
proud you troubleshooted uh a broken capcom mod installation
i didn't think think you had it in you you're stronger than
50% of modders.
My Oshi can read.
They give me the Akasupa.
They give thank you.
He talks like a fucking bond villain.
A fucking coerce.
I thought he was, like, British.
He's just a role playing.
I found he was American all along.
The country on earth come to Raccoon City for one purpose.
To find Elpis.
Elpis.
Yeah, what is Elpis?
the power to upset the military balance of the world the
last virus created by spencer designed to control human
consciousness mind control they couldn't let it be stolen so
they launched the missile strike oh it's a mind control
thing hide a virus why do something so extreme extreme is it
when the president tried to investigate they had him
assassinated and you are the key to retrieving help us
as emily
the sound balance for this game is so fucking weird i will
say
there's more than one there's emily two three and four what
do you mean
copies crafted to duplicate they're me I'm Emily I can bring
her back all scrapped
they each this might sound weird but she looks less blind in
the photo
just the lighting it's just the way it's Wait, is that it?
Was that all the Leon?
30 minutes of troubleshooting for three minutes of shirtless
Leon.
I was like, Doctor, we can't contain you.
Get up now.
Are you kidding me?
Get out of my way.
Was it damn right it was worth it?
And it was worth every second we flew too close to the sun
we really did every second was worth it oh no there's hiding
under the bed mechanic i don't like that weren't they just
here who's chloe who the fuck is chloe oh my god am i emily
five bedtime Which Emily am I?
Which version of Grace am I?
1990.
Wait, that's a long time ago.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's me.
How many fucking Grace's art did they clone?
Are you gonna uninstall it now and install the mod that
makes Grace herself when she uses guns because of weak,
dainty phones?
No, I'm gonna install the mod that makes Grace Leon.
That's your recipe.
yeah that is that before grace was born no it has to be when
grace was born because that they're all grace this is all
grace though no i will say the audio balance for this game
is so wonky like everything else is so good but the audio
balancing is weird don't come any closer why are they bald
oh what the fuck seven minutes seven minutes all we can stay
here for sure I didn't even, we didn't even make it a seven
minutes.
Whoa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for being here.
Get back.
Huh?
He's just touching you.
What's wrong with that?
Oh!
Oh, they touched too hard.
What are you doing?
Oh, no.
Holy shit.
These little girls are strong as fuck.
What the hell?
oh god we gotta go we gotta hide from the other knees the
evil graces bad touch where's my bed where's my bed all
right don't worry i hide why am i playing as chloe like is
am i playing a flashback a flashback of a flashback i'm more
defenseless that's the worst part okay what if i come out
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, it's like the other Resident Evil's where you play a
flashback in the video camera.
It's like, play with us, Chloe.
Play with us.
Oh, it's a flashback in the video of the laptop.
Yeah, it's like the Resident Evil 7 or 8 where you have to
play a flashback in the camera.
That this is much scarier than Grace.
I'm literally a little girl.
Oh, you'll never know.
You're only looking above the bed.
Yeah, see?
You don't know.
Right?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, please leave.
Oh!
Oh, they saw the dead scientists!
So what happened to these girls?
What happened to all the greases?
Okay.
I don't like this.
This is much worse than...
This is definitely...
Someone help me.
It's definitely a lot worse.
A lot worse than...
Oh, they killed...
Already?
They killed her so fast!
hello it did your neck also got broken he's not moving that
was a girl scream that was not a man scream I don't like
this where's the women's scream oh I hate this this is worse
what's worse than a defenseless woman a defenseless little
girl Oh, it's like that Sherry part all over.
Oh, it's like Sherry all over again.
Oh.
I don't know where that's coming from.
Where's that coming from?
Hello?
Is this the same place?
Oh my god, this is the orphanage.
I was gonna say.
This reminds me of literally the sherry part.
Oh.
Oh, they were above me.
Gamers don't look up, guys.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know where the other girls are.
I just hear them giggling.
Oh, my God.
This is worse.
Bring me back the shirtless Leon.
Bring me.
Yeah.
Oh, my God, it is.
It literally is.
sherry part.
I remember it now.
Oh, no.
Why did they have to bring this back?
Why?
No!
They saw me!
I was like, maybe they'll think I'm one of them.
Maybe.
Okay.
I was like, it's fine.
They'll just think I'm one of them.
Just less bald.
You know, it's just less fun.
I thought that was the perfect analysis.
I still don't understand.
Oh, it's from here.
I'm not allowed in the bald club.
Not allowed.
Shung the hair, however.
I hate that I hate that so much Also I hope sound I hope
this sounds okay I did adjust it a little bit Hope it's not
too loud
I have to wait for him Oh my god I hate them
Oh my god wait this is worse This is worse than every grace
part I'm so I can't even kick anyone
I...
Literally one shot, one kill.
Oh, I hate this.
Oh, this is so much worse.
I hate this.
Can't even make them explode.
I'm just a little girl.
Sorry, I can't tell.
You need to play in first place.
Don't look behind you.
Don't look back.
I don't know.
I should be faster than them.
Where are they?
Hello?
Where did they go?
Did they walk back?
Hello?
Wait, they opened the door.
okay hello oh
i hate this i hate this bring me back to shirtless leon what
do you mean it's locked where can i find the key
i don't even have a flashlight
can leon save us leon please
oh my god your hands were long enough your hands were
definitely long enough oh they're right behind me they're
right behind me aren't they they're gonna be like join us
join us Chloe you had to fall you just had to fall didn't
you what What the...
What do I do?
Wait,
what do I do?
What
the fuck?
What do I do?
Oh my god.
I didn't see the hiding spot.
I didn't see it.
I was panicking.
I was just like when I was the little girl.
He's like, what if you were just like the little girl?
You think she'll get up?
Oh, I have to trigger it.
Did I trigger it?
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I would have done the same thing in her instance.
I would have got killed.
I would not have survived.
Do not worry.
I would have been one of the scientists that got killed.
Okay.
Yeah, I grabbed the key.
I think when you grab the key, it auto saves.
Okay.
What the fuck?
She's waiting for her?
They're like, hi, fellow bald girl.
Hello?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, there's nothing here.
It's all, it's so dark.
Just pitch black.
Nothing in the dark corner.
Who would hide in the dark, anyway?
Oh.
Okay, they opened the door.
They opened the door.
Oh, God, that is so scary.
That's actually the worst.
Go in.
Go.
Please.
There's no time.
There's no time to hesitate.
There's actually no time.
No time to explain.
have to book it okay that's fine that's fine it's just be a
bad dream it's fine we just go into the basement we go down
we get locked up in the let's just go down down is up truly
down will lead us to the outside okay we'll just become a
basement child oh good oh why is there a train in the little
of the basement all right that's okay that's okay it's not
weird it's not weird at all we'll just keep running down
okay thomas no thomas before the t virus got him the t virus
was actually named after him Thomas.
Umbrella Corp.
Maybe Wesker will help me.
He's a good guy.
Okay.
The Thomas virus.
Remember him?
That was Thomas when he was small.
When he was a baby.
If he had seven minutes.
Oh, I have to hide.
Okay, never mind.
What's this?
Charlotte, seven years, two months.
Discarded due to volatile symptoms.
Oh, that's another Grace.
Seven years?
How old is Grace?
Yeah, that's a...
I assume that's one of the clones.
How do I open this?
What?
Oh, is this platforming?
Oh, my God, it is.
I can climb this, though.
Can I not?
Oh, I have to pull this out.
Weak as hell.
My legs are not built like that.
Okay, helpies.
How am I going to get down?
Wait a minute.
down from here.
Thumping from inside the coffin?
Which one?
Oh, that was a... Thank you.
Conveniently placed mattress.
Yeah.
Oh my god, the clones are coming out, aren't they?
The clones are gonna come out the moment I get here and have
to run for it.
I fucking it every time every fucking time every time I feel
just a little bit safe there's no such thing as safe in
wrestling what are you okay okay cool I why couldn't I do
that before just fatter away like a fucking fly like a
swatter away like no
Nice fairy!
Plot fairy
Just gotta keep going.
What's wrong with them?
All right, we're in the lab.
We're in the Resident Evil lab What is this place?
Hey, matches your dress?
Chloe
through the series 60 possesses recombient DNA increasing
the volume of Spencer's injected plasma did not result in
successful memory transfer mental abnormalities were
developed we will perform the next medical procedure and
progress to the final phase however after adjusting the
viral load in the blood of series 7 subject Chloe improved
signs of stability were observed we'll continue to monitor
her process oh I'm a good test subject I'm one of the
successful one's.
Oh my God, that's a lot of us.
1987?
Okay, I don't think Grace is.
Is Grace a clone?
Am I Grace?
Like...
Did they...
Is Grace a clone too?
Today was unbelievable.
I somehow got invited to the renowned Oswald E.
Spencer's lab.
I heard rumors about the place, but I think Ark has been
underneath me this entire time.
I was given a quick tour of the attached orphanage too.
The children...
We're all grace.
I am grace.
Apparently they are used for human experiments.
The whole thing gives me goosebumps.
They have built a place like this.
Spencer must have been more in-hanged than any of us
imagined.
Sensational.
The process of being able to freely experiment on those
kids.
Send shivers anticipation throughout my entire body is all
so exciting.
Leon is grace.
If anything, we should be cloning Leon.
Why are we cloning this weak-ass girl?
For now, I'll start by making the rounds at the orphanage
tonight.
It seems like the newbie always gets stuck with the boring
jobs.
Hopefully, I can wrap up the tedious bits quickly.
So we should be cloning Chris and Leon.
Why the fuck are we cloning grace of all people?
Oh, shit.
That's a wrap.
like how many how long have we been cloning her also isn't
there a theory where like if you keep cloning the same
person over and over again like they'll start becoming
dumber and dumber because like the genetic the DNA gets
eroded more and more unless the umbrella court fixed that
are those babies oh wait those are babies those are more
graces Yeah, just like, yeah.
If it's a clone of a clone, a copy of a copy.
But how much DNA do they have of the original grace?
But that's the thing.
There's only, like, a specific amount of times you can clone
one person before the, like, you get, the DNA gets eroded
too much because you have to have, like, enough DNA for it.
That's me.
Oh?
Is that how I...
Oh!
What do you do?
I've got her.
Get over here now.
She's showing symptoms too.
Oh, she's a failure.
We need to get rid of her.
Oh.
She was not the main character, guys.
She was not the main character.
That might mean my mom, like her mom, Grace's mom, kidnapped
her out of the laboratory.
So, like, one of the Grace's could grow up to be a normal
girl.
Bye, clone.
They weren't able to recreate Spencer's key.
Yeah, she's not, she doesn't have the protagonist, buff.
We have you.
Me?
You can unlock Elbasid Ark.
That's where we'll go.
what I I was made correct just like him so I'm glitching out
am I supposed to know I'm I'm man-made he's just remembering
that mom was murdered and oh god I mean she turned into that
that that thing I could have been you you need to Was she
even really my mother?
It's time to embrace your destiny.
Just having a panic attack.
The most realistic depiction of panic attacks ever.
Grace!
Oh fuck, I forgot to turn it off!
Seven minutes.
Seven minutes is online.
Mr. Kennedy.
I had a feeling you'd make an appearance I forgot about it
What the fuck?
My immersion this Wait, what?
Is that X gonna give it?
He's alive?
Welcome back, Leon X gonna give it to you, I'm gonna give it
to you He doesn't have seven minutes to spare.
That's why he's an inferior clone.
I was like, I thought we killed you.
Make him shirtless.
Was there nothing to drown here?
Yes, there was.
There's something again.
Patch arrested thinking with all shit.
Okay, wait.
Do we have...
all right escape that's that's ours right is that is that is
that the newest guys i'm sorry i did okay wait we're still
technically we're still in the police station guys we're
still technically if you think about it we're so we're still
there we're still in the police station i said to deal with
this i said until the police station is over we're still
there though we're still there
Wait.
Oh god, he's so cool.
Very true.
Alright.
Don't worry, we unlocked everything.
Okay.
I am worried a little bit.
Wait a minute, where do we go?
No, wait.
Oh my god, there's stairs.
Oh my god, there's no stairs.
It's here.
Yeah, I got a little lost.
There's a...
Oh, shit!
There was a little red herring.
What the fuck?
Give me a goddamn...
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Apparently we go back here anyway.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, thank you!
Wait, I'm back here!
Wait, what?
Okay, I ran the wrong way.
I got lost again.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
I just went in a circle.
guys i did that on purpose so we can savor the moment yeah
to extend the leon time
guys i didn't get lost i just gave you fan service you're
welcome for the love of the game
head to the orphanage head to the orphanage but apparently
it's someplace important oh guys we gotta leave all right we
gotta save i'm sorry guys the moment we leave the police
station that's the door guys that's the way out
why is leon shirtless i did say guys i did say moment we
leave it's still on the property line toky no you don't have
to leave it on until the next
grace mr broken pod thank you for the aqua soup but keep it
on technically everything in raku city is part of the police
station territory
I mean, keep it off.
You know, because Mr. Broken Bond said keep it on, I guess
we'll have to keep the shirt on, guys.
Say thank you to Mr. Broken Bond, guys.
He's like, oh, it's chilly outside.
I gotta put back on my shirt.
Guys, it's so cold outside, guys.
We escaped RPE.
What do I...
Okay.
Doki stays in the police station for the next six hours.
Gunshot.
Oh, there might be ammo in here.
Guys, he's gonna get cold.
He's gonna get a cold, guys.
Look how cold it is outside.
Huh?
This is where I hide from X going to give it to you.
Yeah, I remember Kendo, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I remember me.
Yeah.
You're a cop.
You're supposed to know something.
How did this happen?
Okay, maybe the shirtless mod would have been inappropriate.
I'm so sorry.
No, I like some spice with my trap.
Never again.
Oh.
Where?
Where is...
The dad's body, though.
Because he, like...
Okay, oh, nice.
Is this better than my other gun?
A leftover from Robert Kendall's gun shop has a full name
stock.
Is this better?
Yeah?
Okay, so we should sell this then.
Um...
We don't have any rifle ammo, so I'm just gonna...
Make some more right now.
uh is this the best shotgun in the game or is the tack
better keep both between a delightful fan service and
gut-wrenching emotion moment this is one hell of a roller
coaster dokey Gordon thank you the super chat thank you
thank you oh the tack is better okay I'll just keep the tack
then I have the tack equipped right yeah I do just want to
be sure Oh,
thank god they had that.
Um...
Yeah, I feel like I should...
Also, somebody...
I saw someone...
Uh...
Oh, wait, actually, let me give me a sec.
Um...
Let's see if I can up...
Hmm...
What do I...
What do I keep, though?
Chat.
Should I keep the old, the tact or the marksman?
Wait, not the marksman.
Sorry, where's my other shotgun?
Sorry, the tact or the police?
Because I don't have a lot of room right now.
Oh, I should, I'm gonna get rid of the classic, actually.
I'm gonna get rid of this.
That's my, that's my old one, right?
I'm gonna get rid of it.
This is my old sniper rifle, right?
oh okay so i'll just keep both my shotgun okay i'll keep
both of it i'll just replace that and now i'll upgrade the
police i'll upgrade this
um where's this and then
all right we'll just upgrade that
let's see basketball court so i'll go this way first oh wait
no actually we have to go to the basketball court
Okay.
Okay, never mind.
I guess we don't go to the basketball court.
He's tacked for a mid-range, and then...
Uh...
Dual-wheeled shotguns.
If only...
If only we can.
I won't put that here, actually.
Makes much sense that both shotguns close together.
Oh!
Mr. X!
What's he trying to do?
What the fuck?
He's gonna nuke Raccoon City again?
Oh shit!
See guys, by wearing this shirt, it protected my babes.
See guys?
I did it for Leon.
He's not X, he's Y.
Mr. Y.
I could stop bastards like you.
Oh my god that aura he's aura farming Oh my god I already
started a second transformation Harry what am I burying oh
this boom oh shit Let me sharpen this real quick I can do
that again want to see
boom that's fucking right
oh what is he doing this tab
that's looking right oh shit i don't know if i can okay i
thought i was a kid i parry a car that'll be pretty cool oh
god oh god i can't double parry.
I can't double parry, but it's okay.
I'll just run away.
All right.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
I parry the world.
Oh, God.
Okay.
He's getting ready to parry a car.
What is he?
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh wait, that was so easy.
I just headshot him That's fucking right do with his hair in
your car, would you?
Oh wait, he's still alive.
Never mind never mind He's still alive.
He's still alive I thought that was so cool What okay, that
was a parry that was a parry Oh, no, don't worry Orange
added some herbs.
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge.
Nice.
Some local herbs can fix it.
Not yet.
It's fucking right.
Oh!
He's like, are you sure?
It's like, not yet.
X had other plans.
Oh god.
okay that's right get out of here I'm dual wielding shotguns
you know I feel like it's not that smart to have his weak
point just be out in the open I feel like they should have
given him some armor for that that's right damn Leon He got
a heart attack.
Yeah, pop this chest pimple.
I feel like maybe they should have, the umbrella should have
like added a little bit of armor to where the exposed heart
is.
X didn't give it to me.
Oh hey.
Is there a random head there?
Oh, wait.
It's supposed to go into a basketball hoop or get anything
from it?
It's like soccer, but with our feet.
I mean, basketball.
It's like basketball with our feet.
Toki, that is soccer.
I fucking knew it.
There's no time.
Okay, never mind.
I was like, it's gonna give me like unlimited ammo or
something they're like it's like the professor oak that
thing is like ash you're not there's time and place for
everything
oh can i up do i have upgrades i don't even know oh wait
there's stuff i missed here
the machine gun ammo the ammo the ammo i didn't need the
injector i even go back or did x block yeah x blocked it He
did.
Oh, I could go back here.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Alright, I should be able to upgrade something now, right?
Wait, try sharpen it?
Yeah, I was gonna say, I was thinking, like, do I need to
sharpen this?
How much?
I was gonna say, that kill should be worth, like, a million
dollars.
Finish up.
I'll finish upgrading my stuff.
That dual wheel shotgun actually came in clutch too.
There's upgrade parts at the station.
How important is it?
Upgrade the Requiem?
Oh yeah.
For Grace.
I don't have enough though.
How important are those upgrades?
On a scale of 1 to 10.
Some charms and a shotgun part.
I don't need.
Charms are for pussies.
We fight our enemies with our bare-naked guns.
We don't need enhancements.
We're clean.
You just want me to go back to the police station for
shirtless Leon.
Don't think I don't know.
There's not much left, but heading underground to look for
Gris.
Oh, I had to go to the lab.
Give him to us.
Was seven minutes not enough, Chad?
It was enough for Wesker.
Oh my god, I rolled and I can't tell where I am now.
Holy shit, this place is so dark.
Is there
anything here?
Oh my god, this tunnel is...
Like, if I...
If there was no flashlight, I could not see anything.
This tunnel fucking sucks!
Oh, thank god, okay.
I get, like, one second of light.
Okay.
The flashlight is low on battery.
You can find more battery back in the police station.
Nice.
Does this take me to the lab?
True.
Alright, I guess we actually need more rifle ammo.
Rifle is so important.
I swear to God, some zombies are scripted to be...
blister head so they don't i shoot them in the head and they
still have it
but it doesn't matter missing herb i don't need no herb
oh maybe i do
it's okay his train is safe huh is that ammo no that's not
ammo it was What is that?
What the- What the fuck?
Okay.
Is that the plants from Resident Evil 2?
In the lab?
Yeah, the plant.
I guess this is messed up.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I did need herb.
Maybe I need...
Wait, they survived?
I thought I burned it all.
What the fuck was the point of making the chemicals?
It was one.
Was there a plant in the plant people?
In two?
Or am I confusing?
Am I getting confused with the labs?
There's so many laboratories, guys.
This dude sucked.
Yeah.
I did.
I missed stuff.
What did I miss?
I'm already losing track of where I've been and where I
haven't been.
Yeah, I remember there were like plant people.
I have lost track of where I've been and where I haven't
been.
Okay.
You guys, I don't need more stuff.
This missile fucking...
What's the point of sending a missile?
Like...
There was no point in bombing Raccoon City if everything was
just gonna live in the end.
it was there but finally reached the bottom yeah this is a
lot of plant a lot of vines
how would they know i don't know when they send in the what
was it called the the little mini army there and they never
reported back if they all died
wait i can't he was right behind oh my god oh my god i can't
see it
Okay, he was right behind me.
Oh my god, that plan was giving Leon backshots.
Yeah, we actually did not need that.
We need more shotgun ammo, I feel.
Wait, can I get that up top?
Must be able to get up there.
Yeah, I can.
Okay, yeah.
Open up, open up, open up!
open up open up open your mouth open up oh he's like oh no i
saw what you did there i saw you what you did come on open
your mouth up open up man
open your mouth i saw what you did to get in here there we
go there we go
He's like, no, I'm not going to open my mouth.
Freaking new.
What?
Why is that moving?
I like that.
Chop!
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Open up.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
I got him, I got him, though.
I got him.
Holy shit, they do so much damage, though.
Alright, it's fine.
I got my meds for days.
His legs was poking out.
I was like, what the fuck?
What's your leg doing over there?
what the fuck this is so bullshit they just slap me for the
sake of there's no like there's no like power to it what's
the lead up to it oh i reload fast on this gun
chop okay that's that's bullshit
me if you chop my toe I would kick you too but still wait
what is there to look oh there is something to look up on
that's right that's damn right I never look up wait
where did it go there was something around here to look up
on was Is it this box?
I thought I saw, like, a loot thing.
Am I imagining stuff?
I thought I saw a box over there.
Unless that's...
What is that?
Yeah.
Where is that?
Oh, it's all the way back here.
Okay.
I got confused.
Oh, it's just handgun ammo, all right.
Like, I need more of that.
I'm just going to reject myself real quick, too.
Just in case.
Oh, yeah, I have way too much heals.
I...
Yes.
Oh, I don't need this.
This crank has a checkmark already.
Can I sell it?
These vows were in there.
Yeah.
Alright, give me your shit.
children.
I'll grow these herbs nice, big, and strong, and they eat
it.
Handgun.
I need more shotgun.
I don't need a handgun.
Yeah, I want to make sure I didn't miss it.
Oh, there is an herb.
Oh, open up.
Open up.
Fucking right.
Open that mouth.
That's right, leave!
No one's better than the SMG.
All right.
Get out of here.
Actually, maybe I should use the SMG.
I'm wasting my bullets on them.
All right, where are they?
Just so you know, I've killed every planet I've ever had.
Damn right.
God, you're so cool, you guys.
Oh shit!
Oh, my god.
He's like, bet?
Okay.
I got too distracted.
Oh, fuck.
These guys are not playing.
Reload.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
No reload.
Okay.
This is bullshit.
It's fine.
I don't need a parry.
I got dodge There you go I don't know the timing yet
There you go Easy I might have got I might have got slammed
at 80 times But easy Oh There you go Why parry when I could
just move to the left and move to the right Too hard this
time.
Cha-cha real smooth.
This must be it.
Alright, we got made up to the lab.
Did I miss anything?
Nah.
Gotta make sure.
Move to the left.
Move to the right.
right two hops this time that's
a big ass door feels inefficient unless we're like
transporting like a fucking truck or some shit i do with a
shuffle i
feel like we use like half the budget on just this door
alone also i just realized umbrella corp is so fucking bad
at keeping their experiments like contained like what has
like not breached breached containment sorry i found some
kind of massive facility it's still or afar what do you
think it is i'm seeing supplies with the logos of the usual
suspects like this is not secure whatever it is clearly
wasn't meant to be found yeah you're telling me yeah it's
not even hard to open it's just fucking lever you would
think there'd be like more pascos involved with this
complicated ass door oh no am i gonna be at grace now it's
been years of oh no thank god okay every time it's like a
black screen of a fate a black screen i feel i i would think
i'd be transported to grace
what if i forgot yeah a comically very large lever I just
want to make sure I didn't miss anything.
Oh, is this a laser room?
This looks like the laser room.
The contamination room.
And I just walked out of it.
Free promotion.
If they breach containment, it's just free advertising.
I mean, I can't argue against that.
Let's see.
See, now everybody knows a secret, very secret organization,
Umbrella Corp.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
That upgrade, all right.
I just need this upgrade.
Oh, nice.
Yes, I should need more shotgun shells.
Current facility operation status.
green network system all areas online oh everything is good
normal normal checking now operate 82 percent holy shit what
are what is a battery power for this must be performed what
the fuck bro that fucking missile did nothing 82 percent oh
yeah i can buy more shock and shells i almost Is that all I
need, actually?
Yeah, that's all I need.
Yeah, it's just...
The self-sustained is crazy.
Okay, we'll put that here.
I don't need that, actually.
But whatever.
What can I make for shotgun shells just because I needed?
Alright.
Oh, do I?
I didn't even realize my body armor was fucked.
Too bad I forgot all about it.
I forgot all about the body armor.
Or bullets.
Alright.
Through that door.
Is it suspiciously?
Hmm.
It's like made to stealth or something.
Very suspicious.
The way this is...
Hmm...
The way this is designed.
Very boss-like for some reason.
What cylinders?
Very unoptimized server room.
Wait, what?
Oh, the red...
The red cylinders?
It just looks really nice.
You mean the glowing one?
Like these glowing ones?
Oh.
It looks like these type of bosses are unkillable.
It's just good for feng shui, guys.
Exactly.
It's all about the feng shui.
He looks very friend-like.
I friend-shaped, Doki.
It's red for friend.
Oh, there was something here.
It's all how we know if they're red, they're friend-shaped.
They're red-colored.
Red means friendly, right, guys?
Let's hope it doesn't escape.
As we all know, Umbrella Corp is very good at making sure
nothing escapes, guys.
That's their motto.
Oh, there's Walmart, Wesker.
Huh?
wait how are they here
I'm getting the feeling I'm not wanted around here oh is
this a security
wait what the fuck why do okay I don't know why I didn't let
me oh shit okay for some reason it wouldn't let me shoot my
gun I got confused
or it wouldn't let me throw the grenade.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Oh my God, they do so much.
Who would have thought bullets do a lot of damage?
Who would have?
My gun does more.
Jokes on him.
My gun does more damage.
I was so used to zombies not fighting back.
Are you serious?
He actually looped around me, he actually looped around me,
he flicked, that fucker flicked me.
Doki, these are trained professionals, that's it.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm playing a Call of Duty now.
This is a different game now.
Come on.
Show me your head.
We're a cover shooter.
Where is he?
Call of Duty umbrella.
But I do not need ammo.
I need like fucking health.
That gun does.
That gun literally destroyed my body shield.
Instantly.
Oh my god, he shot...
He shot the...
Holy shit, they actually took away all my meds.
Where?
That's why they're called elite guards.
There are holes, Stokie.
I don't like it.
The music is still playing.
Oh my god, I don't like it.
Warning, footsteps?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, it's Rainbow Six Siege!
They're breaching!
They're actually breaching!
There you go.
what the fuck am i supposed
oh my god you fucker oh my god i have no more meds i
literally used up all my meds for these guys they're on
point okay wait i can maybe loop it maybe
oh shit oh shit run this oh my god oh ask him a question
just that's it but can i shoot these i never i was scared of
shooting these oh my god i could have shot this the entire
time i didn't know what they were are you serious these
fuckers these actual i'm machine gunning this there's no way
his
when you're right I have enough needs
that's me right oh my god he just got back up he just got I
didn't think you would just stand up like what's the point
I'm grabbing loot while he walks around I'm grabbing loot
fuck this shit I'm gonna grab my loot I'm gonna grab my loot
It takes forever to get to me anyway.
Assemble.
Holy shit.
Alright, here's another name.
Here we go.
Get this guy out of here.
Thank God he has an axe instead of a fucking axe.
god thank the lord what is that i'm not fucking opening that
oh my god i could have opened that that could have made the
fight easier i could
i couldn't realize i could have opened it could have killed
everyone the gun Thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
I'm not gonna open it.
I already killed everybody.
He's friendly.
He does not look friend-shaped.
Out of everybody, he is the least friend-shaped of them all.
I'm so sad.
That literally took up all my...
Took up all my nails.
I had, like, seven.
Guys, it just...
Guys, can you blame me?
It didn't look friend-shaped at all.
But he is red.
Yeah, he is red.
Oh, shit.
Oh, hey, that's nice.
That's a cool diorama.
Your movements will be constantly monitored.
cool i never judge a book by its cover he's an innocent man
trapped against his will free him mr broken bod if he was so
innocent why did they trap him huh
don't you carry a lot of things in this game fyi i think it
was super chat they could thank you i just don't know what
the timing is for the parries Because I like fuck it up a
lot.
As previously stated, ARC is focused on bioweapon research
and development, utilizing the unique environment of Raccoon
City, and particularly experienced performed by infecting
nearby zombies with a mutated T-virus strain, have yielded a
great deal of empirical data.
This has also proven invective against the BSAA's attempt to
eradicate the ARC.
The development of new bioweapons based on this hard data
It's in the final stages.
If said bioweapon is released, we can expect further profit
growth next fiscal year.
ARC has now become a key bioweapon production hub for North
America.
It continues to bring great benefits to both us and the
United States.
Oh, cool.
That's what they say about bioweapons.
Until it doesn't do that.
Until it does the opposite of that.
CMG-002.
$30 million.
Product.
Cerberus has been further enhanced and enlarged, resulting
in increased combat capabilities.
It can track and pursue target speeds exceeding.
Oh, these guys, they were $30 million.
Bro, I think I killed like 20 of these.
Like, hey, these guys, these guys were not worth the money.
That's all I'm going to say.
It took one man.
That's what I'm saying.
We should be cloning Leon.
We should 100% percent be cloning leon um yeah the dogs from
the highway liquor uh originally an infection anomaly
rigorous experimentation reveal yeah it talks like not like
it just takes like one like one bullet and kyle leon is
causing the recession right now uh and like by the way it's
so easy to DNA too that guy is just bleeding everywhere like
like I feel like it's not even that hard to grab his DNA
it's literally there's like it's literally everywhere
um originally an infection among rigorous experimentation
revealed a key to activate a mutation paving the way for
Part of most enhanced climbing capabilities.
A hundred, is that the plant I killed?
Oh yeah, it takes, this takes like just shotgun ammo.
Like, we have definitely wasted our money on these
experiments.
Tired.
Oh my god, $120 million?
I will have to say, if that took $120 million, dollars you
could have spent a million a million of that creating an
armor making sure the heart isn't fucking pulsating out of
his body like or create a little like body armor a little
tiny heart heart body armor
or you can get one tired or four silly dogs Fudge top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's true.
It's like the Apple.
It's like the iPhone, guys.
They gotta make like, they gotta make sure it's a little
weak so they have to keep buying new bio weapons.
I'm like, don't worry.
The next upgrade is even better, guys.
Did your tyrant die by an axe to his heart?
Don't worry.
The tyrant, the tyrant 8 is even faster, stronger, and he
will wear armor.
The eye tyrant.
It can execute simple commands.
It says tracking and limiting targets.
And comes with a coat as standard for effective human
disguise.
So effective.
It should come with a hat too.
The time pro 9 max.
It has a very obvious flaw so they can fix it.
Yeah, it has a very obvious flaw so they can fix it on the
next update.
Armor not included.
not a good username thank you thank you let's go try to end
the world in five to avoid paying his bills thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you how do you do fellow
humans the nemesis based on the umbrella corporations
parasitist parasitic this mass produce oh is the is the
nemesis gonna come back guys i think if because all the
other all the other products i like how I feel like, I feel,
oh, the mass-produced model focuses on cost reduction and
performance.
That's never like, whenever they add mass-produced and cost
reduction, it tells me that it's not very good as the
original.
I don't know.
They did say cost reduction.
Maybe it's made of plastic.
not necessary I'll neutralize the target myself whoa holy
shit maybe that's the Leon clone he has his own axe guys
who's this guy how does he know my name hello oh my gosh
that's CQC oh my god it's CQC see oh my god there you go oh
my gosh he knows there you go my what okay I was healing
heal rules bitch okay all right there you go okay there you
go Oh shit!
Wait, he can use his gun?
I thought we're CQCing!
What do you mean?
I thought it's knife only mode.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently it is knife only.
What?
I don't parry that?
Okay, I don't parry that.
I don't parry that.
Oh, my.
Okay, we both hit each other.
There you go.
No, my axe is very healthy, by the way.
It's like full HP right now.
You're bad for someone at death's door.
There you go.
How sweet.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
He does so much.
Oh.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Sneaky bastard.
Oh shit.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
I died.
I sandbagged on purpose so I can keep all my heels, guys.
I'll
Guys I did that on purpose because now now that I warmed up
it's different.
See watch this Oh, shit.
I heard you were a smart ass.
Here you go Oh my god That's that's actually insane What
Get out of here, you cheater.
I didn't use shit.
Wait, I'm already at the second stage.
I hope it's not because they're adjusting the difficulty
because of what I did.
I can still see you in the smoke.
Like, you're not fucking...
You're not like...
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Get out of here!
That's right.
I hope it's not because they adjusted the difficulty after I
got absolutely destroyed.
See, guys, I told you.
Who is this guy?
Nice.
Fatality.
They saw the first attempt and the game was like, okay, we
gotta...
Oh, yeah.
You're like, hmm.
His axe.
Did I grab it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, the mortal axe.
Did I already equip it?
Is it this?
I mean, it's metal.
How is that better than my axe?
Oh, yeah, no.
That's definitely better than my axe.
This axe looks like it's made by vibranium or some shit.
like that's right cqc
all right probably alive there's no way look at him he's
dead dead
see oh bet easier parries that's what i like to hear where
do i go oh right leave the room and come back you just all
right who's hunk what game was he from oh he's gone oh my
god the blood is gone he makes sure oh wait okay no what
he's gone did he crawl away
oh shit he was like he played the classic pretend to be dead
he actually possum to his way up hunk wasn't Resident Evil 2
I'm trying to remember I'm trying to remember him He's the
fourth survivor, human unit never killed, never killed.
I'm trying to remember him in Resident Evil 2.
Oh, it's in the DLC.
I didn't play the DLC.
That's how it's late.
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way.
Grace should be just up ahead.
Alright, Grace.
Where are you at?
Grace.
this is where we are the world is under threat the
technology to control another's will already exists but it's
not efficient at infecting others i believe spencer solved
that with elpis the connection sealed raccoon city to save
it for themselves and it's been waiting here ever since
us the creator desire as far as we could get they not just
like run it through code will be destroyed oh never mind so
tell me grace so they only one shot one what if like they do
a typo i don't know of course you do you're the leon don't
embarrass yourself mr kennedy you can't beat me Oh wait, he
got the mold.
Seven minutes.
Aren't we fancy?
Oh, okay, that's- oh shit!
It was just that easy to cut his arm off.
Never mind.
It was not that easy.
That's a nice gun though.
I want it.
The password.
Oops.
Oh fuck.
Pro healed the shirt.
Nanomachines.
Oh?
You still need me.
Oh, she's smart.
That's smart.
He didn't call her bluff.
If she didn't do it, when Leon gave her bullets she's not
gonna do it now
i would call her bluff
i got you
are you okay me i feel like a million bucks i feel like
cloning a leon is cheaper than all the fucking experiments
they've done all the other bio weapons your guess is good as
mine
oh leon see look he left a trail of dna already he coughed
there just he swabbed that shit.
Oh, Leon!
Leon, wake up!
Literally, he literally just coughed up DNA with his blood.
On the property of Umbrella.
They could literally just swab that.
October 9th.
Aww.
Oh.
Oh shit, the mold.
The mold is spreading.
The black mold.
Leon, are you okay?
I don't know.
But, uh, wild.
Oh, those marks.
It's T-virus.
The Thomas virus?
If you're so...
say why would you come here what's the difference between
this t virus and the zombie t virus
this place like why isn't he zombified cocoon city was where
it all began for me he's gonna turn into a train what all
happened i i couldn't couldn't make a difference so why i'm
here oh this one just kills you Why are they just all called
T-viruses?
He said something about you having a password.
What was he talking about?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
Hey.
I'm going back.
I'm going to destroy Elvis.
I'm coming with you.
No, you're not.
I don't want any more regrets.
whatever it takes come in
oh character development she's going through a character arc
she's not pussy no more
she's like I'm no longer the little girl you saw in the
hospital I only break one bone when I shoot the Requiem oh
no why would you but Leon is right there you can't just show
me leon and then make me play grace oh yeah leon adopts
another blonde child i think it's there there's a door over
there to get grace that's even worse the fact that he they
show me leon and then i have to play grace i can check it
out for us okay because they a super chat that you think you
didn't want to know in the past is it boobs you the super
chat thank you thank you the grace period wrong this is a
reward you get to watch leon now you get to you get to have
him walk in front of you watch out for yourself up there
yeah oh that's true would you rather escort grace that is
true That is a good argument.
That is a good argument.
Leon can defend himself.
Okay, let's see.
All right.
Leon, I know you have eight guns up there.
Throw one of them.
Leon, you have eight guns.
You can spare one of them.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
thank you thank you like you have two shotguns you can spare
you can throw me one of them like umbrella could become the
richest company in history they clone leon to sell them to
every woman in the world thank you with a super chat marshal
they could literally pivot they don't need bio weapons they
just need very thirsty people
that's fucking crazy leon literally all the types of zombies
and soldiers in this lab and then he was like that's cool
i'll keep the two
shotguns that's that's cool that's that's fine let me keep
my one pistol i need all 15 of my guns for my 32 backup
plans oh my god i need a key Fire for re-activation.
Is that not it?
What is that?
Oh, it's locked.
Oh, okay.
I thought that was not...
I didn't see that.
It was glass or anything.
That's so crazy.
I still can't get over the fact that Leon didn't even spare
it.
Like, ammo.
Ammo is easy to throw.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Not even, like, what?
One stack of ammo.
He's like, you're on your own, girl.
I'm fucking dying.
Alright.
None of this would help me.
That's cool.
That wouldn't help me.
I never brought the crafting materials.
Alright.
Back to typewriters.
Burying me with my guns.
He would rather die with his guns.
all right would you buy leon code from umbrella after
rebranding dokey think of the super chat a fucking course
sydney and think yeah who would it he could be a bodyguard
oh critical error containment lockdown oh wow another
another experiment escaped from containment who would i
thought wow another must be a Tuesday.
Oh, shit.
Not a goddamn liquor.
You know what's been good right now?
Forgets a liquor?
A fucking shotgun, Leon.
Oh, my God.
I can't even kill it, too.
I have to sell for this, too, because I don't have the guns
to...
It's okay.
It's no longer okay.
I hate you, Grace.
I fucking hate you.
Just die.
Let it happen.
Just let it happen.
I just...
Alright.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh my god, I'm not used to...
I had...
I had seven hours of Leon, and now I have to go back to
stealth mode with grace.
Now...
After seven hours of Leon...
No more pew pew.
I can't see.
God, look at that ass though.
There's another one!
Oh my god.
That fucking sucks.
Oh
my god.
It like...
Okay.
Oh, jokie.
There's more than just another one.
Why would they do this to me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
There's no way they would put a zombie there.
Why not when the residents are evil?
Does it see me if I'm just under it?
What if I make him kill that one?
I want him to kill that guy.
No, not me.
Not me.
There you go.
That guy over there.
Yeah, that guy.
Yeah, him.
Kill him.
Say that.
What?
Come on.
Kill him.
Whoa!
They
would fight!
Oh, I did not keep those bottles, guys.
I legitimately thought they would fight.
I thought they would fight each other.
I thought that was the whole plan.
No team killing.
Okay, I still have one more Molly.
Why won't he climb up?
Climb up.
No, no, don't come back.
No.
But this sucks.
This sucks.
I hate Gracie's section so much.
I can't go anywhere!
that's how i'm shooting his ass oh what
if i
there i baited it
trying to bait it out
there we go
okay it's fine that's fine that's fine
if it sees the zombies no no he doesn't see the zombies he
doesn't see the zombies Maybe a friendly fire.
Maybe no friendly fire.
There's him!
There's you!
Oh god What
is this?
What is this?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh shit,
oh shit, oh shit!
It's okay.
I'm so healthy.
I am so healthy.
No!
Oh god, okay, that's good, that's good, that's good See,
it's that, oh It's that easy
Okay, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we go,
there we go, there we go, Okay, there we go, there we go,
it's fine
There we go, let's see, everything is fine, everything is
fine, everything Everything is fine, everything is fine,
everything is fine, Ooh, everything is fine.
Guys, we're so healthy.
It's all...
Oh, stop.
Everything worked out.
Can I use the blood to make anything?
No, I don't have scraps.
What did I grab?
Hello?
Follow from the other side.
I don't think he saw me.
He's so slow.
It's fine.
I can walk around this.
It's the liquors I have to be worried about.
Look at him.
He's just slouching.
See, look at that.
What's he gonna do?
Walk through that door?
Look at him.
He walked through that door.
Okay, I didn't think he knew how to use the door,
apparently.
He knew how to use the door.
How is that supposed to know that?
Don't jinx it.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that he would walk
through that door?
The dump?
Oh, the electricity here.
The zombies...
Okay, it's bullshit that the zombies knew how to put their
hands on a thing.
And then...
It's okay, they're blind.
Alright.
They taught him how to use the hand scanners.
Or like, use, put your hand there.
Wait, fuck the guy is like, you might be following you.
I actually Looked behind me
Yeah All
right, Leon Be careful It's just a central Refine Why can't
I just go with Leon Why can't I just I don't understand Why
can't I just go with Leon I don't understand Nice
Yeah, but that's a different zombie guys Those aren't the
mutated, mutated zombies that knew how to use the gun.
This zombie was naked.
The other zombie was naked, guys.
Come on, climb the wall.
Come on, the fucking wall.
Oh, my God, not the stairs.
I didn't say climb the stairs.
Oh, no, no, no.
Yeah.
it.
It's okay.
So I don't need those bottles.
I'll need those bottles.
All right, we're good to go.
It's a stupid card.
It's okay.
I can find more bottles.
Wait, I should save.
We'll casually walk over there.
I still have a ways to go.
All right.
I wonder if Leon's made it yet.
Okay.
Huh?
Threat level red in storage sector.
See, I told you guys.
I told you guys I could find another bottle.
Checking database access request.
The following data was found.
Minutes of the 51st assembly meeting as contrived by AI
control center.
We heard the key.
Grace has finally been found.
It's been 28 years since we occupied Ark.
Are you sure she's the one?
doubt there's need no need to worry most importantly don't
you think your withdrawal from the treaty is too blatant the
state it's a bluff the united states is and always will be
at the center of the world the bsa are fully under control
as well are there any changes in product supply rx factory
automation is constantly involving i believe that they said
red right and you guys said red is good remember?
Red alert is good alert.
We'll discuss further while we view the products.
Oh my god.
The government is in on it.
I now craft a bottle of acid and various what are the
various other items?
I don't know the password for this.
Unless guys, we do know the password of this.
Unless what is this Blood and bottle.
Oh, I have so many of that.
What did I find other than that?
Oh, I could craft this now.
The game was like, um...
The game actually gave me...
They're like various...
Look at all these items that you've missed out on.
What is that?
Is that a bottle?
Oh, is that...
Yeah, it gave me all the recipes that I missed.
Or is that the...
Oh, that's the injector, right?
No.
I think so.
Oh, I could have had more HP.
Or is that the med injector?
I can't even tell what that is.
I wonder if that's the emo...
Here you go.
Can you forgot?
Yeah, man.
If only I had the Requiem for that.
Alright.
I'll use, I'm gonna use this on the first liquor I see.
No, I meant like the steroids, uh, craft.
Alright, where is that fucker?
Oh.
I hear him.
Oh my god, he's so close by.
Where is he?
Where is this fucker?
I know he's here.
Oh my god, he's right there.
That's right.
BAM!
That's fucking right.
Surely there's not another one.
Alright, 10, 90, 20.
Okay guys, guys.
10, 90, 20.
Wait, 10 left, 90, right.
20 left.
Alright, let's grab that real quick.
Surely there's not like five more, right?
Surely that's the only one I hear is, is there like...
Okay, 10.
And then...
Oh, I fucked it up already.
10.
And then...
90.
And then 20.
There you go.
Wait, was that not this one?
Oh, wait, it's 10 left.
Fuck.
Okay.
I already messed it up.
It was 10 left.
10.
90.
Oh, is this the wrong safe?
20.
I don't remember the arrows.
Yeah, nope, never mind.
I don't know.
I saw, like, one safe path.
where I assume it's the first one I saw I was so hyped too I
was like there has to be equipment for another one all right
I thought that was the emergency supply
room well the lakers gone did he fucking also walk started
walking where did this guy go?
I don't like that.
He's just God.
Oh, nice.
Upgrade.
Soon I'll have one-eighth of Leon's pockets.
I could just kill this guy.
Wait, I could make another acid.
Wait, actually, I'm gonna make more.
I have found...
Yeah, I'm gonna make another pot.
I'm Walter whiting give me a sec we're gonna cook
all right we're gonna cook real quick we need more acid
yeah but if i alert all the liquors i can get them all
bunched up to you know watch this guys oh wait i forgot i
don't need a cook inside i i got my games mixed up guys i
got my games mixed up i forgot i could just do that i i got
my i was thinking about pocapea did you guys know i just
found out that the reason why it's called pocapea is because
uh you it's it's a utopia for pokemon so it's a pocapea
because it's a utopia
all right watch this watch this guys i'm gonna for all of
you guys watch this okay and then that can't be the only one
whatever oh well i thought more will come out
all right i i did think like 80 more would start running
over but i guess not oh shit can these guys died by my
injectors they can okay nice that's good I knew I kept those
injectors for some reason
all right God I hate all these groaning noises.
Wait, can I use injectors on lickers?
Oh, I don't know that.
That actually makes it a lot easier.
Actually makes everything a lot easier now.
Yeah.
Oh, we'll make more injectors.
Yeah, where's the other guy?
Alright.
what I hear him you're so close oh there he is I was like
you're so close by
I'll grab this guy oh
yeah I don't have enough blood but
I think I can do it
Wait, I should think I can stealth this guy.
Let's go!
That's fucking gold!
Got you on your ass!
Or your back.
Oh, I just don't have blood, though.
Oh, fuck.
The only issue is that I don't have any blood anymore.
Wait, is that the other one?
80.
Is that the other one for the one upstairs?
Blue is back.
Okay, we'll go back for it after I open this.
Never mind.
I'm going all the way back for all...
Fuck this.
I'm going all the way back for all the other blood.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I'm going all the way back.
I left a lot of blood back there.
Occupy.
fight yeah bro that no no i'm not gonna shoot it that guy i
these these gonna take like 80 bullets for me to kill him
grabbing this safe gave him some what was the code guys i
didn't look i didn't i didn't think about it let's put the
zombie inside the box oh i left 50 Uh, right 60, left 80.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, shit, nice.
Actually, we need all of that.
Okay, I can make another ass.
Yeah, nice.
I'll just go all the way back.
Wait, actually, no.
I'll just chuck this at the last guy.
Actually, no.
Let me...
Fuck yeah, I'm gonna make more.
Wait, yeah, I don't have enough.
I don't want to go back and grab some blood.
Are you still here?
Nah, he's gone.
Nah, fuck.
I'll kill this guy.
Damn!
He should be dead.
There we go.
Give me your blood.
Come on.
Bro, you're so cheap.
Can't even suck the blood out.
Alright, I'll grab this.
Okay.
I'm gonna craft one injector for the zombie in the little
box.
And then another acid.
Which I don't even know if I have enough for that.
Oh, shit.
Wait, actually?
I do.
It's 80.
there you go worth it maybe get max HP it's all right grace
grace will be fine
that's okay I believe in grace yeah she doesn't need that
she'll be fine oh wait was there safe back there there was
no safe back there what are you talking about where
was it oh here oh
my god i didn't even realize i forgot about this door what
is this area the clean room doesn't look so clean don't
think they did much cleaning here
oh hey it's the orb one of the objects needed to enter the
administration oh i needed this
Oh, that's fine.
It's just these guys.
Bam!
Get pushed!
I'm reloading.
Alright, let's shoot you in the head now.
I'm done playing around.
Unless!
There we go.
Get out of here.
Give me your blood.
the triple kick what the fuck you're all so cheap only one
zombie had blood on him oh my god really only one zombie
decided to decide to have blood on them oh I can make this
MNIC zombie.
Oh shit.
Oh sorry guys.
Sorry for interrupting your private hour.
Wait, there was something I missed here at Molotov.
Yeah?
Oh.
I fucking knew it, man.
I could never have nice things.
There we go.
Oh, at least you have blood.
It was worth it.
It's a little bass pillow.
They're very soft.
Apparently there's a safe here?
Is it here or somewhere else?
Guys, where is the other safe?
I don't remember where it is.
Oh, in this room?
Uh...
I hugged.
I was just like, yeah.
Nah, I can't be buddy.
I'll just kill it.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, nice.
I can make more acid.
What was it, guys?
I don't remember the code.
Chat.
What was the code, guys?
Do they untie in the other room?
He doesn't understand.
Oh, wait, I have this.
Wait, that was...
Is it this?
Oh, 10.
Uh, 10 left.
90 right.
Okay.
10 left.
90 right.
And then left 20, I believe.
There you go.
Does that give me...
Oh, nice.
More body.
Oh, Molotov.
Injective.
here nice um means i can make another oh no not another
bottle of acid i thought i could make another bottle of acid
but it's not all right let's go
all right and then we can save
i don't need the blood bag yet because i have nothing to
craft
it.
Yeah, I don't think I... Yeah, I don't have...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's a knife?
Do I need a knife?
Let's grab a knife.
Fuck it, just for fun.
No, I don't have any... Oh, I do have an empty bottle.
I didn't even realize.
Alright, let's...
Alright.
Nah.
I don't need to see... Grace doesn't need that upgrade.
Footsteps.
That's my own footsteps.
Yeah, I can turn into scrap.
I was thinking that, too.
Unless I want to stab somebody.
I mean, I could stab the zombie in the box.
The occupied box.
I'll just throw the acid on the liquor.
And then stab the zombie.
Alright.
Welcome to London.
I'm ready.
I'm not gonna knife fight the liquor, guys.
I'm gonna give him the London hospitality.
Leon would.
Yeah, and Leon has 20 guns.
We can't all be Leon, unfortunately.
Wait, where's the liquor?
stab oh not that
everything that could go wrong went wrong
i wanted to stab him but not that kind of stabbing
wrong button oh my god he doesn't okay he left stuff okay
that's good at least he left blood
All right, we're going to turn one of them into scrap, I
guess.
Okay, then at least I can make another one of this.
And then I can also...
Oh, there we go.
There's, like, one more zombie.
I think he's in here.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
Okay, and now, now I'll equip this.
Oh my god, I can't even stab him because of it.
That's fuck it.
Fuck it.
I'll just...
There we go.
Fuck it.
I can't even stab him.
He only gives 20 blood?
What is wrong with you?
Drink more water.
Say hi, drink.
guys so I can so I can get that blood out of you later yeah
at least he dropped something so I can suck that blood out
of you later they're old zombies I'm so hungry I got
everything I think I did
Noah, reboot, failure.
No response.
Containment protocol, inactive.
What's this?
Okay, the second floor plan.
Alright, I got the orb.
I got the orb.
Open the door to the central refining.
Where's that?
I'm already so lost, honestly.
I don't know where that is.
I've lost track.
Oh, did I miss loot?
Oh, I did.
How did I get that?
Oh, here.
Oh, shit, wait.
Wait, what?
What?
Are you telling me that I can only carry a...
Oh, I can only carry three injectors?
Grace.
Actually, Grace.
What is wrong with you?
Alright, oh wait, that's not...
Where's my blood bag?
Oh, there it is.
Like, Leon can't hold eight!
in his pocket.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, there's the liquor.
I just throw it from here.
Nah.
Actually, I'm just gonna use my injector.
It's less of a waste.
Because he's just right here.
I feel like injectors are easier to craft.
All right, back shot.
I mean, if I want blood, I guess I'll use the non-injector.
All right, he's gonna come over.
Get out of here.
Give me that sweet blood.
Om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om.
That's right.
Blood for the blood, guys.
Oh,
it's in here.
Empty bottle.
Another acid.
Look at that.
Never punished.
That's right.
This is nothing to me now.
This is my character arc.
Okay, nice.
See, I can actually make another injector.
I think?
Oh, no, I can't.
I need more blood.
Give me more blood.
Now drop down here.
Yeah, see, I told you.
It's like a character arc.
She's getting stronger.
I don't even know how much...
Oh, I'm fine.
My HP's at fine.
That... Oh, yeah.
I even... Keep forgetting I have a blood bag.
And I can craft...
This.
Oh, yeah.
I don't have enough, though, for...
there we go double kill wait what okay come on okay there we
go I he was like I'm all right wait is that acid oh shit he
got confused yeah okay there we go He was like, what is that
on my body?
Oh, shit, it's acid.
Oh, wait.
I'm weak to this.
He remembered the script.
They're paid actors.
They were actually paid actors, guys.
I'm going to save here.
Is it this?
Is this where the orbs are supposed to go?
Oh, it is.
Orb one.
Orb two.
Oh, that's me!
This lore?
No.
Alright.
Time for lore!
I have pondered my orbs.
What is this?
Something important.
Oh!
It's my journal.
It's from my journal, yeah.
The creator.
Letter from Patrick.
Who the fuck is Patrick?
Is that Spencer?
Oh, his mom!
Life takes unexpected turns, don't you think?
Do you feel that the choices you've made have contributed to
your present circumstances?
Of course.
What you sow, you reap.
Isn't that the natural order?
So tell me, Lord Spencer, what would you like the world to
know?
The truth.
The truth?
short break before we begin miss ashcroft it's john t virus
himself
oh that barely gave me any lore
why would mom hide this
that's me
okay they can't just give me a cliffhanger and then swap the
leon i mean that's great i get to play as leon but like
But still, like, come on.
I worked so hard to learn about Grace.
I worked so hard to learn about her.
Grace cleared the way for me.
They can and will take it.
Oh, now you don't want to play.
No, I just want 30 more seconds of lore.
You just sent us a charm before immediate event.
I thought you wanted more Leon time.
They fucking cucked me out of grace lore.
That worked so hard for it.
All right, my 80 guns.
I'm ready.
Containment breach.
System-wide, surveillance, failure, detected.
And my Requiem bullet.
Requiem out.
What would I need the Requiem?
for that where is my requiem gun wait where is it wait where
did it go where did it my stupid i don't see it in my
inventory okay what oh there it is it's just giant ass gun
there there you go that was stupid over there is his all
right we'll shoot the liquor with this oh shit that's not a
liquor i mean these guys i can just pistol them like it
that's right give me that stick boom that's right that's
right easiest kill oh my god that was so easy compared to
the shit I had to go through.
Just kill everything.
Oh no.
Oh no, Leon, please.
Leon, sudden bouts of blur visual cause him, he can only
wait for these.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god, Leon, please.
Please.
Oh wait, it doesn't matter.
I can still fight.
Like, that doesn't matter.
That doesn't matter.
That doesn't nerf me.
they're just status effects
all right can I go right or out here it's just cosmetics I
can still shoot my gun all right all right what can I do
here I'll grab a body armor repair injector because by God I
need a lot of those right now shotgun ammo oh yeah I should
upgrade my hatch oh wait my hatch is technically fully
upgraded everything is fine now you can't do the back flips
no more isn't my rec room already upgraded I don't even
remember oh no I have not done any upgrades on it whoops
it's already so strong, guys.
It's already so strong.
I just gotta make sure I reload every gun I have.
Yeah.
Gotta make sure every gun is reloaded before I go in.
Oh, that's a lot of zombies in my zombie room.
Security threat detected.
Elevator shut down.
in effect override key authorization required that's a lot
of zombie pods guys
why is there so many zombie pods in my zombie game
yeah i have to do something here oh shit 10 000 let's go
what if i'm gonna go back and upgrade that
Now I can upgrade my Requiem.
Let's grab that in here.
That little oomph.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
More damage!
Alright, when do the zombies come out of the zombie pie?
Or when there's a freaky eye zombie.
All right, I'm ready, lickers.
I'm ready.
I'm ready?
Oh, there they are.
What's he gonna do?
Come on, climb up.
I dare you.
The climb up.
Is he climbing up?
Oh shit, Wade, he's climbing up.
I haven't changed much.
There you go.
I'm behind you.
He's bending.
Yeah, why did he give her a back?
The long way.
What the fuck?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, he was bending.
I'm gonna take out as many of you fuckers as I can.
shit oh shit leon oh my god okay that was there we go that
was sick look at that look at that i told you i could parry
even when i'm coughing my lungs out congrats on 800k for the
girlfriend go thank you super chat fan and thank you thank
you guys i can't believe it like under a month too guys
thank you so much for the crazy ass support on that cover i
did not expect to go when i first when i was working on this
cover i did not expect it to go that well so thank you guys
thank you everyone for the insane support i really
appreciate it i'm so happy you guys like this what the what
i was like where is he but yes i'll officially start
production on skater boy i know i could have started it
early because eventually we were gonna get but i'm sorry i
didn't start the production yet because i had a million
other things things going on.
But I'll officially start the production tomorrow, not
today, because I need to rest up.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for all the support on Skaterboy.
I'm not scared for a girlfriend.
I'm like super surprised it did so well.
Like, I did not expect it at all.
I was like really worried it was not gonna do well.
But I really appreciate it, everybody.
for the insane support.
Yeah, I don't want to rush it too.
I want to make sure it's that perfect for all of you guys.
Well, Skater Boy and Girlfriend are my favorite Avril Levine
songs.
I'm just getting rid of all of them.
But...
There's no point in stealthing.
I'm not... I ain't no grace.
That's...
Whoa!
Stay!
Okay.
Reflex!
Yeah, it made me realize, like, that my song, my voice is
good for it, for punk pop.
I was like, what the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Like, where the fuck did that guy come from?
Did anyone get the license plate on him?
oh that's a bad that's a that's a red one red equals bad
that's right sorry red equals good all right nice
all right i'll use the shotgun ammo next
all right we got another override key sort of electricity
and battle weapon okay here That's for that area.
Boop.
E-poop-poop-pop.
Red is friend.
Yeah, I was letting the friend out of the pod, guys.
I was just letting him...
He was so stuffy in that pod.
I was just letting him breathe.
Oh, I hear people in the pod.
You know what?
Watch this.
Okay, I was expecting them to...
Oh, shit!
Watch what?
Okay, I fucked up.
I fucked up, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit!
Give me a sec.
I did not realize how many there are here okay okay give me
a sec and then oh fuck okay um don't worry don't worry i
have a plan i have a plan trust the process where the fuck
is the grenade where is the okay trust the process guys oh
fuck oh that's a smoke grenade that's
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
So healthy.
Perry!
there we go see there you go nothing to worry about guys not
just as planned okay um so there might have been a slight
miscalculation there might have been a very slight
miscalculation is okay I was trying to find this grenade but
I might have used the wrong one just a tiny little oopsie
guys just a just a tiny mistake um
it's like it's okay i figured it out i figured it out guys
nothing to worry about nothing to worry about at all i don't
need i don't need a robot to tell me how to sort my
inventory wait do they have do the others have ammo too
wait i gotta check Oh, there was a grenade in here.
There we go.
That should have missed the box?
Nah.
I just want to make sure.
Now, those boxes aren't openable.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait, which box?
Where are that box?
box at.
Oh, in that room?
Oh, my God.
It's right in front of me.
Hello.
There's too many boxes, guys.
Too many boxes.
Look, see?
I got everything under control.
I have everything under control, guys.
You know, it would have been nice if I was able to shoot
that.
It would have been.
I, I miscalculated just exactly how many liquors were in
there.
I might have miscalculated.
Oh, okay.
Um, there you go.
Autoclave compromised.
Poth lockdown unavailable.
Oh, that's not good.
Memory corrupt.
Self-prepare functionality.
That's not good.
Oh.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that is absolutely not good.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's get this over with.
Oh, God.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
This is it.
Boom!
There we go.
See?
I did it.
What the fuck?
Okay, get your ass out of here.
See, look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
The elevator has arrived.
Yeah, that one wasn't smoke.
Thank God.
Alright, that was easier.
That was a lot easier than the liquor That's for sure.
Eh.
I can't waste any more time here.
Yeah, but the headshots were cooler, though.
Yeah, but did you see the sick headshot flex I got, though?
Nah, that's fine.
I have a lot of save on my side.
Yeah, now I can shoot this for fun.
Yeah.
See, I don't need no handouts from the game.
Guys.
I don't need no handouts.
I don't need the games to show me how to do it.
Oh, he is not doing so well.
Oh, no, Leon.
Breathe.
Breathe that black mold in your lungs.
You got this, Leon.
There's no way you can die.
There's no way they will never kill you off.
You make too much money.
They sold 5 million copies in like less than a week, Leon.
They literally need you.
Not done yet.
Alright.
It's okay.
Just five more steps, Leon.
Leon, you can make it.
You can make it.
You're almost there.
Where do I go?
Do I go towards the light?
Go towards the light, Leon.
It's literally yellow.
It's yellow-coated for us.
I like that I made it yellow, so that will definitely go
there.
Just to remind us to, like, please go right.
Yellow for victory.
Oh, oh, thank God.
Okay, we finally figure out what the grace video is.
Not finally, I said I get to play grace, but finally the
cliffhanger.
What kind of legacy do you want to leave behind?
I did not realize three hours has already passed.
This game is so good.
I could literally play this I could have actually finished
this game in one setting last stream I don't love grace I
just want to know what the fuck is Elfis blind hope what do
you mean humans cannot predict when death will come for them
this is why they have hope I was wrong and I am plagued by
guilt
the expense of others I think that's enough for today what
the fuck why did you accept my request for yeah oh is that
grace oh who is that is that one of your subjects of course
not she was alone in the world I took her in to make humans
is she perfectly normal just an average child needing a home
wait well i'm perfectly normal why do they want me is my
hope aren't you beautiful would you like to hold her yeah
i'm not a mutant i don't have so i don't have anything in me
I'm not special, but Timu Wesker said I was special.
That doesn't make sense.
She's adorable.
What's her name?
Grace.
She's Hope.
She's Elpis.
So she is Elpis.
Is there anything else you'd like to tell me?
And I've said my peace.
I only hope it serves as a requiem for those who have...
You're special because you're not special.
No, I'm normal.
So she has trauma for no reason.
Oh, fuck.
That is a lot of DNA that they can use.
Like, it's literally free real estate.
Like, free real estate for...
He's begging to be cloned.
He's literally begging to be cloned right now.
See that again?
Wait, where the...
Oh, it's this way.
The door, the red door is now green.
I swear to God, I got my ass it out.
Oh, there's Spencer's wheelchair.
There's his wheelchair.
Wait, am I?
Am I?
Okay, all right.
Okay, I was just like, where am I?
All right.
Elevator tap.
Yeah, I was just saying.
Like, am I...
Like... Like, am I in the...
Wait, was there something on the desk?
I don't think I can interact with anything on the desk.
No, it was just this chair.
Leon is dying.
Yeah, but what about loot, guys?
No, this is still...
This is still the...
Leon, just give me like five seconds.
See, look, I'm coming back now.
This is finally my chance to do something.
Yeah, Leon would want the loot.
Leon would have wanted this, guys.
What if there's more?
There, see?
Look, I told you.
He couldn't wait like five seconds, guys.
Leon!
I know it took a while, but don't worry, I was just grabbing
loot.
You would have wanted it this way.
Hey, it's me.
It's Grace.
Please wake up.
Come on.
Wake up.
Hey.
Hey you.
I was just resting my eyes.
Yeah, he was just napping.
Napping on the job, Leon?
Let me help you.
Let's do this.
Okay.
It's the final countdown.
It's Grace.
You left the wide open for us.
Any wrong code will do.
It'll destroy all this.
Grace, whatever it takes.
I can buy you some time.
No.
No, no, I have an idea.
I trust you.
The idea.
Bro, thank you for chatting.
Thank you, thank you.
I like how he's just watching him struggle.
The prodigal daughter of returns.
i know the password i do fulfill your destiny and all will
be is it grace because he's help this is me or hope very
well it's hope really elpis is hope release hope to the
world please know that you are my hope she yeah it's hope
release it to the world okay
i knew it i'm fucking new i'm so smart i knew it was hope
they were like hope hope hope racist hope hope this hope
that if it's hope it can't be that bad hope can't be bad
sure I didn't fuck up right they said it was a good thing to
release it what
are you doing grace Spencer regretted what he did he yeah
release hope to the world you promised yes it's opium yeah
so that should fix him right huh mr.
Kennedy did it fix him you the honor of experiencing my
power firsthand I'm not sure Elvis is what you think it is
there's nothing special about me I was never any key Spencer
wanted to make amends he wait is he normal wait he's normal
now he's cured tell me
he's cured we fixed him we fixed the flashbulb this is
spencer's atonement it's an antiviral oh my god it is he
took the normal pills he's a normie now Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
He's alive.
Amazing.
It's the Hope Serum.
I'm humbled by my master's genius.
He's just a man now.
Your research was wrong.
Elpis wasn't a weapon.
There was never a key.
Spencer's paper was obviously incomplete.
There was no connection between Grace and Emily.
Do you know how much time and money I wasted?
Like, she shouldn't have killed Alyssa.
With Elpis, all virus-based weapons are useless.
The world order will be thrown into chaos.
Oh my god, he's able to twist anything into a weapon.
Instead, Spencer gave us anarchy.
Yeah, he's like, he's always evil.
And bring his vision to life.
You.
You and Spencer were a means to you.
an end yet he outwitted you all spencer defied us and paid
the price with his life he was nothing you while they're
dialoguing expositioning we should be cheering the odd right
now i think they're distracting grace the connections is
done with you
we can't wait to have it
like that's it he turns into a normie and is just dead
staggering yeah it's a cure that's fucking it okay i will
say timu westker is definitely timu westker leon is working
wake up it's he's definitely
I literally just he's just dead all of that build-up just to
get sliced just to turn into a normie gets sliced yeah all
that aura farming for what
it's gonna go grab something Leon
is now you're right he's at full power he's cured Yo, he
looks younger now.
Oh my god, all that ammo, too.
Oh, shit.
They always say that, but there's always a last skeleton.
Oh my god, this boss music.
Bro got vaccinated.
Wait, that's not...
Yeah, Perry.
it is brought to fruition oh he just kicks me how many more
will have to die for that
that's right but that's not right
right sacrifices must be made wait i can't why can't i pair
you i can't i don't know this
Okay.
Not to me.
That's right.
Good kick.
I know it's protect those lives.
It's okay.
I'll just keep shooting.
All right.
What is he doing?
Can I shoot that?
I don't know if I was supposed to shoot that.
I couldn't.
Oh, shit.
Oh, run.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh, I should run, I should run.
I forgot the first stack.
Oh shit, it's okay, I have this.
Get covered!
Oh!
Fuck!
Oh, fuck!
Oh no, I ran out of ammo.
Are you serious?
I'm hearing that!
Is it over?
Guys, I no longer think it's over.
Boy, it is over.
But that was so easy.
He's letting the beast out.
That was it?
Watch how he's stimming.
That was easy.
Oh.
Okay.
I was gonna say there's no way that was the last fight.
What the fuck?
What do I shoot?
A nemesis?!
You're so damn relentless.
He's morbid.
Oh, when do I shoot?
Okay, there, I see it.
I see the heart.
I'm reloading, but I see it.
Okay.
Okay, I think I parried that.
I have to reload, though.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I shoot.
Oh, there.
There we go.
God, Mitch, I'm focusing so hard.
Right now.
Oh, shit.
Not enough.
Apparently not enough, though.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Where is it?
Where are the pimples?
There we go.
Pop the pimples!
Oh, what?
I can't bury the grass?
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, generator exploding.
Pop!
That's simple!
BAM!
That's right.
Wait, could you ever...
Leon, a dermatologist.
Fucking easy.
Oh!
Oh, Leon!
Asta la vista.
This time, you ain't getting back up.
One-handed Requiem.
That's right.
That's Leon on full power.
Grace, where are you?
Sherry.
Sherry, come in.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
Leon, full power.
Easiest boss fight of my life.
Saw that 100% parry rate the moment Leon gets cured.
Leon.
We need to get you out of here.
It's a Peter Griffin.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, because she got stabbed in her kidneys.
There's no way out, is there?
Comment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You had a shirtless mod with all those damn parries.
Oh.
I don't think the PC would be ready to handle that, guys.
We're just going to sit here.
I'm going to sit right here with you.
What the fuck, Leon?
We fucking cured you.
He's gonna give up.
Huh?
Oh.
I guess this is it then.
No!
What's that?
He came back!
He came for us!
No man left behind!
Leon F.
Kennedy?
That's me.
Depends who's asking.
That's the BSA?
Yeah.
Is Chris's team?
Team Wolf?
Yes, sir.
Mr. Kennedy.
I have a message from Captain Redfield.
Chris!
Continue the bloodline.
We have to remove you because you got too close to that
other girl.
Chris found out you were talking to another woman, so he
sent us over.
over
i'll be damned i can't believe that antiviral actually
worked feel better than i have in ages oh thank god did it
give it to sherry i'm glad you're okay we got a dose with
your name on it we'll be back in action in no time oh soon
thank you leon Claire is almost hitting menopause.
Where is Chris anyway?
No idea.
It's too busy punching some rocks.
Yeah, I'll call you back.
It's over then.
Yeah.
Opus really was our last hope.
Well, its prayer umbrella hasn't left us any more nasty
surprises.
I wish we could have saved Emily Finally, this will be the
last surprise Umbrella gives us, surely Surely, right, guys?
She could still be alive There's no way there's gonna be
another surprise
That's what they said In the last eight other Resident Evil
games
The government has confirmed the existence Of an actively
trading bio-weapons lab Located here in the ruins of raccoon
city the origin point for the worldwide oh yeah he put on a
wedding ring this illegal facility appears to have been in
operation for decades sources say that the extension of the
lockdown and the recent series of mysterious deaths may be
related to tragic events in raccoon city 28 years ago
evidence seized in raccoon city has led the justice
department to reopen its investigation into oswald spencer
and the long defunct um corporation some believe the
government deliberately drove umbrella into bankruptcy the
late Alyssa Ashcroft is credited with cracking the Oswell
Spencer story conspiracy theorists are already claiming that
she was killed in a cover-up oh my god they couldn't pay her
off they finally stopped paying off the media our government
tonight in a speech from the Oval Office the president is
expected to reject allegations of any government involvement
since the All the conspiracy theorists.
All the conspiracy theorists in the Resident Evil world.
They were right.
They were justified.
Young girl rescued.
Wait, what?
What?
She was in the monster.
Still alive?
Oh, it was like a cocoon.
Release the raccoon files.
Release the umbrella files.
Mr. President.
Oh, shit.
That means there was like a little cocoon for her to
regenerate.
I can't believe Emily's still alive.
She didn't shoot.
He didn't shoot the vitals.
I was aiming for the head.
I...
It didn't matter.
How the fuck was I?
I know he didn't say he didn't shoot the vitals, but I was
aiming for the head.
I did not think that she was gonna live.
That's fine.
It's just gonna be like...
It's gonna take the ad revenue.
It's okay, guys.
Um...
By the way, the monsters beyond killed cost so much money.
Young 20 to 30 to 120 million.
They even search out the thing.
That's what I'm saying.
It's cheaper to just...
Leon, Leon, like then all these fucking race clones.
841, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank
you.
No spoilers, please make sure to watch till after the
credits.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Bum, bum, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bum, bump,
bump.
That's fun though, I really, um i really i've i really
enjoyed this game i think like uh i've always loved like the
rest of evil games more than a silent hill game because it's
more action-y than i mean there are horror moments but i
love the action moments and it's just so campy i'd be like
resident evil is like my metal gear in terms of like the
writing and i just love the writing for it it's just pretty
silly sometimes uh battle cake thank you welcome to tomato
fight welcome but it's why i also don't want to play I
personally don't really want to play seven or eight because
like seven or eight is actual true horror and yeah it's so
over top like seven and eight is just actual horror horror
so that's why like I didn't I didn't ever I never played it
but I loved like um I love like the more action-y parts of
Resident Evil um next thing thank you the super chat thank
you thank you so we're saying this takes the ad revenue
getting the video restricted didn't actually matter thank
you super chat thank you thank you well i didn't know it
that was gonna be dmca song i didn't know
it is action but eight follows seven so it's like you have
to play seven and sort of like know what the is going on in
eight i unless they're like so it's more so and i know guys
i know you want me to play eight because of the dummy mommy
i know
guys i know why you want me to play eight
yes but i definitely enjoyed i definitely i do have some
questions I was like, like, who was the original Grace then?
Like, what was, like, who was the original Grace?
Like, what was the purpose?
Is it just experimentation?
I guess, like, child experimentations, I guess, like, for,
like, human father to use as experiments?
Yeah, I know Grace is just a normal girl, but I meant the
clones.
But doesn't, isn't Grace part of King?
She's not a clone.
orphan?
Oh, I thought because she looked like the clones.
Oh, she got gaslighted.
I think she was clone.
Oh, okay.
I thought so she was just a normal orphan.
Just a normal random orphan that just happens to look like
the fucking clones.
Oh, I see.
Phantom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's the next playthrough?
Well, I'll be on vacation next week on wait, I won't start
when I start my vacation so there's no schedule for next
week and it's going to be a whatever I do go to vacation um
I won't I um uh I'll be it'll take like a week my vacation
lasts around a week so I won't be back until the vacation is
over so there's no schedule for next week I will be
streaming I'll maybe I'll I will be streaming on Sunday um
uh I'll be streaming on Sunday so I'll just let you guys
know that uh but basically it's just going to be a gorilla
week uh gorilla week until I'm uh but i'm not sure what i'll
play next but i had a lot of fun i really love i really love
this i love this version of resident evil i just i
personally think this was the best resident evil that
they've either i like this or resident evil 4 it's between
resident evil 4 and resident evil 9 i think those are my two
favorite resident evil games uh fudge shop thank you the
super chat thank you thank you resident evil 8 has you fight
a mech while driving a tank also in Resident Evil 6.
Leon fights the Team Rex.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Which is the... Which Resident Evil?
Where Chris punches a rock?
Which one is that?
Four didn't have Grace, but they did have Ashley.
Five?
Okay, we might have to play five in the future.
We might have to play five in the future.
Because I want to see him punch a rock.
I want to see the meme live.
I want to experience it.
What's worse?
Grace or Ashley?
100%.
Because like when Grace had her stupid Emily section, at
least like Emily can't touch the floor.
She needs a very comfy couch to sit on.
If you want to put her away.
Ashley, you can put her in the closet and then that's that.
And then just be like, bye.
You're like, Ashley, stay in the closet and then do
everything.
And then.
And then get her out.
uh gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
doki what you don't realize if they clone leon there'll be
no more wars because everyone wants to smooch their clone
boyfriend and the economy will crash thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you that's the risk i'm willing to take
next thing you think of the super chat thank you thank you
they're clones of her but the thing is there were i don't
know she's just the thing is i didn't know she was just a
clone or just a normal girl but and also like there were
clones before her you know because it was like 1990 or some
shit they were like and there were still clones of the
little girl they've been cloning for so long so i don't as i
was like grace can't be there's no way if grace was part of
the clones she can't be the original clone because uh
they've been cloning uh because she's like what 24 right
yeah she was just a coincidence that apparently she looked
like the other orphans
uh lord kerosus think of the super chat thank you thank you
um gotta drag a friend into five experience peak co-op is
that the one wait resident evil five is that the africa one
oh resident evil five is like my dead space three it suffers
the same Dead Space 3 curse.
Every time I swear to I've tried to play Resident Evil 5, I
think three times.
Every time I find someone to play Resident Evil 5 with the
playthrough dies.
it's also my Dead Space 3.
I could never finish.
I could never get past the first chapter.
every time it has my Dead Space 3 curse I never get to
finish either of those games
no I'm gonna play with someone who's never played Resident
Evil 5 with because like I've been having that on the back
burner I've always wanted to play Resident Evil 5 for the
longest time as a collab but like everyone has played
Resident Evil 5 because it's such a classic it's such like a
I buy one play it with someone that's never played it before
and the thing is a lot of people have played Resident Evil 5
because it's such a classic game and that like I've asked a
lot of people about like have you ever played Resident Evil
5 and they're all like yeah we played it and I was just like
oh damn so you managed to break your god of war curse it's
time to break this one Marty thank you the super chat thank
you thank you that one was easy i'll tell you guys this all
the suggestions you're giving like nine a hundred percent
they've already played it good i'm so glad emily yeah uh
she's doing great i'm actually teaching her how to read she
doesn't know how to read oh because she's blind okay wait
does the Wait, does Elpis unblind her?
No, fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy.
No, that guy should be fired.
He should be fired.
He should not be the FBI director.
That unblinded...
Oh, she's not blinded.
Oh, she's...
I Elpis'd her.
I unblinded her.
I cured her blindness.
I'm blinded.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
I was like, oh, yeah, I was just like, you don't know how to
read?
What's wrong with you?
But I was like, oh, because she was blind the entire time.
There's this guy.
Oh, is that hunk?
Remaining PSAA forces have been neutralized.
Retrieving the objective before they send in the wolves.
Who are we retrieving?
What?
Yeah!
Who are you retrieving?
Unlocked in standing mode.
Behind the scenes video.
Grace's report.
Special content models.
Leon jacket.
Tactical life.
Deja vu.
That's a lot of challenges.
Unlock.
concept art oh I have to pay for my concept art no fucking
way what is this is this like oh my god this is literally
like 60 pages of X lore dump like what the fuck this is
actually 60 pages of lore 60 pages of retconning oh my god
They're like, all right, let's record everything.
Here's 60 pages.
Read it.
Oh, it's chronological, too.
Don't worry.
Okay, I'm going to scroll through all of this.
And then everyone who doesn't have Resident Evil Requiem,
but want to learn about the Resident Evil lore, just pause
and read it.
Just pause the video later in the vibe.
There we go.
conclusion all right tldr what should i remain shrouded
countless lives has been lost as government officials oh my
god i don't even get to like have a vacation like she has to
come in here and write the 60 page report um sxr thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you google dockey thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you what's this
behind the scenes video
oh that's so cool I've worn these suits before with the not
with the camera though because the motion capture for for
expression is done by like put a hold on that for now we
found another body one that exhibits the same pathology it's
very interesting like the face expression is done by a
different person if it's live because like when dancing
dancing and doing facial like it's like that it's very
blocky to have it on so like it's it's on another person for
the thing grace or is either two ways is either someone
would hold the controller and control the expressions or um
or like another person um is with the facial tracker for it
if it's dancing or anything like for like non-extensive
stuff like this it's fine to have the camera like have the
face camera mount but if it's dancing like obviously it's
it's very intrusive and during dance scenes but it's other
other like it's tracking the other person's facial or um or
they have like a little like controller where they like like
the facial expressions are tied to a controller and they
press buttons on it
But after much effort, here we finally are.
Who are you?
I know now that you're the one that I've been serving.
Is this the voice actors doing it too?
The special one.
The chosen one.
Oh my god, that's a lot of shit on her back.
Lady.
Help me.
Are you okay?
Oh my god.
Are we gonna get to the kiss?
What are you doing?
Oh, no!
Hey!
That's not the kiss!
Wait, is that?
Robbed!
We were robbed!
We
were robbed!
She's so good.
The actress is so good.
The fact that you have to be able to act this out and also
do like recordings for it too.
Because there's no way.
I'm pretty sure, there's no way they're recording the
dialogue during motion capture.
But you have to be a good physical actor as well as a voice
actor.
Because that's really hard.
Being able to be both a voice actor and a regular actor as
well.
Yeah, I feel like she should win voice actress of the year.
For voice actress of the year.
for gaming the facial expression we don't even get to see
that we don't even get to see their faces oh my god is that
Emily on the I don't think Emily's a little girl guys I
don't think she's a little girl
Emily does not look like she's seven Gia grew up.
The worst part about wearing these suits is when you have to
go on a bathroom break.
They actually added an extender on the gun too.
Oh, is that the voice actor for Honk?
Oh, it is here.
Oh, shit.
That's cool.
I love seeing these.
Grace!
to bury him brother's last skeleton holy shit he's so cool
i love that's cool i love watching the motion capture it's
so interesting there's this youtube channel that i watch
where it's like a chinese motion capture studio and like the
like their their star motion capture actress is so good she
like rep she like recreates motion capture for like various
like games and stuff and she's so expressive um i love
watching it i don't remember the channel name um because it
hasn't shown up in my recommended in a while but she is
incredibly expressive like let me see again what is it
called i saw someone um because she like she does like
distinguish like oh this is what motion like this is how
this is like regular movement and then this is motion
capture movement like be more trying to be the more
exaggerate like exaggeration with her stuff um I know
there's her channel but there's also like one that's like
the uh the motion capture studio channel does anyone
remember what the motion capture studio channel is or is it
the Sakana official it's expressive slash exaggerated yeah
this isn't the one I was thinking of there's one that was
like so I want the oh there you go yeah I was uh because
like before she made her own
on the official motion capture studio channel.
Yeah, I'll show you guys.
Oh, is it gone now?
Is the channel gone?
Let's see.
I swear to God, it was a different chat.
It wasn't this one.
Wait.
Double check.
Was it actually?
Because I was watching the one with...
She had a different one.
There was a different...
I guess the channel's got...
Aw.
Yeah, because there was a different...
There was a...
She had a...
There was a different channel with her in it.
I think they...
Did it...
Is it gone or is it still around?
Because they did have an official YouTube channel.
I just don't remember.
Let's see.
I don't see it anymore.
Uh...
I remember they had a YouTube I had they had maybe they
rebranded maybe I remember they had a YouTube channel
because they would have like the Overwatch she did like the
Overwatch stuff too let me see I can find it
yeah I don't see it anymore yeah no I used to I don't find
it was a different channel and they did like she did like
Overwatch motion capture.
Like, recreated Overwatch motion capture stuff.
Why don't she get no more?
That's sad.
No, it was like the studios.
It was the studio one.
But they had it on YouTube.
Not the, not Sakana's channel.
Because the studio one was that it had a lot of subscribers
and viewers.
I don't see it anymore.
And it showed, like, everyone else.
It showed, like, all the other motion capture.
capture actors and actresses there not just the girl so but
like I don't I think they're still on Twitter right they're
still on Twitter but I don't see their I don't see their uh
their YouTube anymore that's weird oh
well but you can see her you see some of her videos here
because I remember it showing up in my recommended like like
before 20 like before 20 25 Because she made this channel,
um, August 15, 2025, and it was before that.
Yeah, it's so cool.
It's just so cool seeing, like, the difference in motion
capture with, like, exaggeration and, um, like, exaggeration
and realistic.
If anyone wants to look into it, I...
It's pretty cool.
Hey, guys!
That was a fun stream.
You can go for the other ending.
there's another oh yeah there was the leon ending the
destroy or whatever right where leon was like destroy it and
then i was like what the fuck are you talking about elvis's
hope
um no because it's a bad ending i don't want to feel bad
yeah yeah i feel a hope right now i don't want to
feel bad i i got hope guys don't take my hope away from me
hey guys i'm gonna call it here everybody i hope you guys
had a fun time watching uh of course i had a great time
streaming tomorrow there will be a stream tomorrow it might
be i think it'll be a 5 p.m pst stream um um but uh i don't
know what i'm gonna play uh it'll just be like gorilla stuff
i'll figure out what i played but anyways as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
they get that blood flowing and if you step for me head to
bed cause you deserve it i hope you guys had fun watching i
had a great time playing this game honestly this is this in
resident evil i think it's a it's hard to tell i love the
leon sections in resident evil in resident evil requiem i
hated the gray sections um recently before i get to play all
leon um so it's hard for me i like the most um i did enjoy
the story in requiem more than four um um and four did have
ashley sections so it and oh yeah four did have ashley
sections i almost forgot uh and requiem had gray sections so
you know they both they're both like counter each other out
for that like
so um so i can't really tell which one I like more because
they both have their pros and cons um and as always
everybody say hi dirty pause check it out and move around to
get that blood flow and you stay up for me head to bed cause
you deserve it I'll see you guys tomorrow or next time
everybody bye guys
my secret secret ending because I forgot uh the dokey merch
dokey merch uh anniversary pre-orders have been extended for
a week so if you guys haven't uh got your Doki, the
anniversary Doki merch stuff, like the plushies or anything
yet.
We are extending the pre-orders for another week.
So make sure to grab the mini Doki's before it's too late.
Before it's too late.
Whoa, where's the picture of it?
Here you go.
The mini Doki's.
Oh, I need to reset this.
Grab it before it's too late, guys.
The pre-order.
Yay!
Doki merch.com.
everyone.
All right, for real.
Bye-bye.